cooking great food doesn't mean you have
to spend a fortune on fancy equipment
get some basic essentials and you'll be
set in the kitchen saucepans I mean
basically you don't need a collection of
ten all you need weenies to a
medium-sized one followed by a large one
a small pans great for sources heating
liquids or rice whereas your large pan
gives you space perfect for pastas Jews
or when you're cooking in bulk which
keeps cost down made from copper to
stainless steel fine what's right for
you and always get a lid which helps
heat the pan up as quickly as possible
and the secret behind a great saucepan
is the heavier the bottom the more heat
you'll conduct
the thinner the bottom the more charge
you've got actually burning with food
buy the best sauce pans you can afford
take good care of them and the last few
years saving you money in the long run
this is my quick guide to kitchen knives
basically three knives a heavy duty
chopping knife followed by a small
paring knife which is brilliant for
prepping vegetables and then this baby
here a serrated edge knife for carving
and slicing basically that is it before
you buy a knife hold it your hand and
make sure it feels right for you the
secret behind a great set of knives is
in the handle if you're comfortable
holding the handle your cutting you so
much easier the firm of the grip the
better chopping the heavier the handle
and more control we've got over the
blade with these three knives you can't
go wrong to get the most out of your
spices there's only one piece of kit
that you need pencil and water I mean
they look fantastic and it's essential
for any good kitchen these things are so
versatile these ancient kitchen tools
are perfect for everything from pesto's
to dressings and custom around 15 quid
used to grind spices and your max out on
flavor
get perfect textures and always be
totally in control make sure you got a
nice large circumference of the bowl
they can grind away the heavy and the
more durable they are and what
conference it gives you when you're
pounding and it's almost a way of
confirming homemade hand-pounded grab
yourself a pestle and mortar and soon
you'll be spicing with ease frying-pan
for me one of my favorites
why because it's so versatile whether
you're searing the most amazing rack of
lamb cooking duck breasts so ting
chicken or even a quick omelet or even
find an egg all in one look for an
ovenproof frying pan with a metal handle
if you want to cook like pros by
finishing off your dish in the oven or
under a hot grill just don't forget when
you take it out the handle will be hot
if you can get a high-quality nonstick
one with a thick heavy base which will
dispute the heat evenly brilliant here's
my quick guide to two essentials you
need for bacon scales and a sieve bacon
is so popular now these scales are
absolutely essential especially you have
to follow the recipe to the exact gram
these digital scales are so easy to
follow they can convert from pounds and
ounces to kilos and grams and more
importantly so much easier to use than
your mama's old weights absolutely
perfect a sieve
make sure you get one with a long handle
and balancing hooks so you can rest it
over your mixing bowl or a panel easy
thing to have in the drawer cost nothing
but it's so effective especially with
bacon with these two pieces of kit
definitely on the right road to baking
like a pro
casserole dish absolutely essential when
it comes to good home cooking why so
versatile the beauty of this thing is
the fact that you can actually use it on
the hob or start it on the hob and
finish in the oven more importantly cast
iron it conducts the heat so you can
have the gas on absolute minimal well
the oven down to its absolute lowest
setting and thing will just cook
naturally casserole dishes are
surprisingly versatile and a great
investment
you only need one and if you look after
it will last you a lifetime brilliance
for one-pot wonders chopping boards for
brunch one of the most useful things is
a great chopping board get the right one
and will be your friend for life I
prefer a sort of heavy-duty one because
there's so much more durable they can be
flipped over the minute you want to go
from vegetables to prepping fish or meat
always keep a little Jake off underneath
that actually stops the board from
sliding careful you wouldn't board by
rubbing it with oil every so often any
cooking oil will do wooden boards for me
always the best easy to clean and long
lasting when you do wash your wooden
board you never let it stand in water or
put it in the dishwasher
as it may split by the best you can
afford and take good care of it when it
comes to simple cooking there are two
basic bits of kit I'm never without that
will save you time and effort in the
kitchen i grater and a peeler these
swivel peeler a stainless steel one
absolute incredible is almost like a
lifesaver in the kitchen because they
are so quick so light swivel blade so
got so much more flexibility actually go
around the vegetable and we call it a
speed peeler in a professional kitchen
because it does literally absolutely
rapidly peels your vegetables you have
minimal waste good peelers cost from a
couple of quid and are great for
everything from peeling bread to finely
slicing cheese and making showers of
chocolate a good comfortable grip and a
sharp stainless steel blade ensures
you'll always work faster
the box grater is another great
versatile kitchen tool and with his
playing four cores grating fine grating
and super fine as well as blades for
slicing it's perfect for everything from
puring ginger and zesting lemons to
shredding onions super small so they can
caramelize in a flash and be sure to get
a solid handle to hold it firm it's got
such volume inside doesn't crush a thing
up so I always prefer to grate onto a
tray or into a bowl so you don't have to
move it again grating onto the board
you've always got to lift it up and
place it in so place the grater into
Bowl and great to simple but essential
speedy bits of kit guaranteed to make
your life in the kitchen easier roasting
and baking tray these things so
versatile great for baking whole fish on
and testing for making breads and so
cheap a classic to handle roasting tray
brilliant for roasting whole Birds
finishing sauces gravies on top of the
stove over the gas stirring burner again
versatile the more solid your trays are
the better then they won't buckle and
they will last cheap but seriously
essential if you have fruit that's not
perfectly ripe the tip is to put a
banana in a paper bag then add your
unripe fruit put in a dark place